so conjuration is arguably my only gift
in this world the ability to conjure
regular hunt hunt content uploaded
straight into your youtube feed that is
however my ability comes with quite the
restriction which is that it requires my
targets to press the subscribe button
then and only then
can the full glory of this ability be on
display hello and welcome to the new
world review your source for everything
anime and manga and today it would of
course be time to continue our journey
through the nen power system of hunter
hunter and today we are focusing purely
on the art of conjuration now i'm sure
you're all sick of me saying this by now
but on the off chance that you are new
to the concept of nen then i would
highly recommend watching this video
first which aims to provide a general
breakdown and provides a lot of assumed
knowledge for this video but delving
into conjuration the most basic
explanation of this affinity is engaging
in the ability to craft physical
constructs
out of one's aura and initially this
might sound very similar to a mission
you know separating your orifice on
purpose
except that conjuration takes us a step
further by transforming aura
into an object that can exist
independently of its user as well
as be seen by non-end users so for
example let's take razer an emitter his
most basic use of that affinity would be
turning a portion of his aura into a
ball now if this idea were to be applied
to conjuration then acondro would not
only be able to devote part of the aura
into making the ball
but it would also become say a full-on
soccer ball basketball volleyball
whatever bowl type of ball ball thing
the user really wanted and it would also
be visible to non-end users in general
anyway these objects can go on to be
hidden by using ian but that's not what
we experience for the most part
so in many ways conjuration is kind of
like a mixture between emission and
transmutation aura that is separated and
takes shape but with the physical
characteristics of a particular
substance and so just as with
transmutation a conjurer needs to have
an innate understanding
of the objects that they are crafting
because it's not a simple task of saying
oh i want to will a chain into existence
because you need to make certain
decisions regarding what kind of metal
that chain would be how big and thick
the links are how many links there are
going to be
are they rusty are they smooth etc etc
all sorts of stuff like that that a
conjurer needs to envisage
each and every time they create
something and according to izunavi a nen
user invoking conjuration
should only decide what to conjure after
extraordinarily careful consideration
because it takes an astonishing amount
of concentration
and training but it's not quite that
simple because conjurers here are
invoking the power of creation
and so this also gives them the ability
to alter the established properties of
constructs that they make and this is
because if they were only capable of
making things that already exist in
reality
then conjuration would be a rather
redundant utility ability so the main
crux of conjuration has more to do with
how a user alters objects that they
craft
and that grants us a huge variety of
creative results
before we get into that though i do need
to check in with professor hisoka for
his personality test and according to
him
conjurers tend to be highly strong
overly serious and sometimes
nervous individuals they are generally
highly analytical and invoke their craft
for very deliberate and logical purposes
and i have to say of all of the
personality definitions thus far hisoka
is pretty bang on with this one
although there are always going to be
exceptions yes chitu i'm looking at you
but to get into some more specifics let
us start with the most famous of
conjurers in the series being karapika
so i used him as an example before in
regards to conjuring chains but karapika
is quite a special conjurer in many ways
and he quite rapidly mastered the art
form to suit his own personal needs
which has resulted in the option of
conjuring five different chains in
battle
each of which has a specific purpose and
often a special conjured end
such as the dowsing chain which looks
like a simple ball but we get more and
more complex with examples like the holy
chain which takes the form of a detailed
little cross for healing via enhancement
and i'm not going to go through all of
them here because graphica is the kind
of men user that you could spend a whole
video on just
explaining the abilities of especially
due to his dual typing but krapika is so
advanced that he has the ability to
conjure any of these chains into
existence at a moment's notice which
means that he has undergone some pretty
intensive vision training in order to do
so but moving on to a more simplistic
application of conjuration i would
present cortopi a very underrated and
undefeated member of the phantom troop
who has a handy little ability known as
gallery fake this allows core topi to
touch a real-life object with his left
hand
and produce an exact replica of it with
his right hand but why would you want to
do this because earlier i said that
conjuring objects that already exist is
more or less pointless well there's a
bit more to gallery fake than that
although i do firstly want to recognize
that due to the nature of this ability
cortopi does not have to engage in any
strict mental work he just needs to
touch an object and then bam he can make
an exact atomically perfect copy which
is actually kind of insane but in
addition to this coretopia is then able
to track the movements of all of the
copied objects and on top of everything
after 24 hours the copied objects vanish
from existence entirely and when i say
objects
yes cortopi can use gallery fake on
people but it will only replicate their
bodies meaning that he would essentially
create a lifeless corpse which was used
on one occasion to fake the deaths of
the phantom troop during the york new
city arc
as well as incredibly effectively in
combination with other borrowed powers
by crollow
in heaven's arena so it's quite a simple
sounding yet very intriguing use of
conjuration to be able to perfectly
replicate objects with minimal effort
but for a strictly limited time period
it's a pretty wonderful balance
and perfect for a group of thieves to
make use of and staying with the phantom
troop for now another very well known
conjurer here would have to be shizuku
who takes the discipline a bit further
than we've explored thus far and uses
her aura to bring a living vacuum
cleaner by the name of blinky into
existence who can suck
up seemingly an infinity of non-living
objects but the main thing i want to
highlight here is a whole new branch of
conjuration
in regards to making living things which
actually gives rise to an entire
subsection of nan being the creation of
nine beasts
a category that i have already explored
before on the channel but it basically
refers to living then construct stuff
like blinky but a slew of other great
examples would be every other guardian
spirit beast present in the succession
war they were all products of the sea
dome which was originally conjured into
existence by the first king of the kakin
empire which then used its particular
unique abilities in combination with
blood from all the princes to craft a
series of nine beasts now there is of
course another affinity you can use to
make nun beasts which is a mission but
the large majority of living nang
creations tend to be conjuration because
it is a more natural path to achieve the
end result
and the only reason really why you would
use emission instead is if conjuration
is too far removed from one's personal
spot on the nen ring furthermore the use
of nen beast does usually require
dipping into some manipulation in order
to control them with that said the first
example being blinky
until stated otherwise appears to be a
use of pure conjuration although shizuku
does need to very specifically tell
blinky what to do
which may imply a form of manipulation
or it could just be a very naturally
obedient vacuum
and for a similar example we need to
travel all the way to the chimera
antarctic to discover a certain kite who
is a natural conjurer and his crazy
slots ability
is very much the epitome of phenomenal
maximization of this affinity much like
shizuku it begins with kite conjuring a
living existence
a clown thing to be precise which does
appear to have a life and personality of
its own and kite would not seem to be
capable of manipulating it at all but
the clown then activates a roulette and
whatever number that rule it lands on
results in kite conjuring a specific
weapon from the clown now saying it like
that crazy slot sounds like very
roundabout way of achieving kait's goal
i mean for example if he needs a scythe
then why not go ahead and conjure a
scythe himself without going through the
risk of gambling and while that's
because taking that risk is
everything it is what makes crazy slot
so powerful in the world of men adding
restrictions and limitations
is almost a straightforward multiplier
of power of the resulting ability in
question
and the more difficult the restriction
the greater that multiplication is going
to be
and this is a pretty damn heavy
restriction at any given time kite can
only fight with a random weapon
and he cannot re-roll until he actually
uses the weapon so when it does land on
the slot number representing the scythe
it results in a weapon of incredible
power but kite is then forced to use
that
even in situations that don't
necessarily call for the scythe however
it doesn't even end there because kite
has placed a further restriction on the
scythe itself and assumingly all of the
weapons and crazy slots but in this
particular example
kite can only use the scythe one way to
invoke the silent waltz technique that
is literally the only thing he can use
it for but it results in one of the most
devastatingly powerful attacks that we
have ever seen in nen user before
thanks essentially to a double
multiplying factor applied to pure
conjuration so while karapika might be
the most famous conjuring hunt hunter i
have no reservations in stating that
kind is probably the greatest conjurer
that we have encountered thus far
especially because he doesn't dip into
other affinities for crazy slots this is
just pure conjuration
taken to its extreme but now from the
greatest user to probably the
greatest failure of conjuration let's
briefly very briefly look at chitu and
look i put this guy as the undisputed
number one on my top five worst nine
users list
and for very good reason because he does
incredibly poorly thought out things
like conjure a crossbow that fires an
arrow slower than chito himself can
travel and i guess the claw at the end
of said crossbow might be mildly useful
but all around this is completely
counter-intuitive to chitu's needs as
well as the goal of conjuration in
general although to be fair chitu did
possess one incredibly impressive
ability which was the tag hatsu in which
he actually conjured a pocket dimension
which is pretty astounding use of nun
although unfortunately the rules he
applied to this dimension
also did not suit his needs and
furthermore in order to create it a very
harsh restriction was applied whereby if
tutu ever lost his game of tag then he
would never be able to use the ability
again which of course he did when he was
easily outwitted by moral but for what i
would say is a better example of pocket
dimensions we do have to mention the
figure of nov a conjurer who took
everything that was impressive about
cheetah's ability
and actually made it good which presents
itself in the hide and seekatsu so nov's
pocket dimension consisted of a four
level mansion structure with 21 rooms of
varying sizes and also rooms that were
entirely separate from one another with
nov being the only individual
capable of traveling between them in
addition to this he could also conjure
portal style entrances and exits do his
pocket dimension back to the real world
and create an extensive network that had
the potential to completely
revolutionize both travel and storage
all of which was integral during the
chimera and r but it's just insane to
think about because at the very least i
cannot imagine the sheer aura output
that nov would have needed to dish into
this ability in order to conjure it in
the first place especially because there
are no real known individual drawbacks
to nov himself there are plenty of
restrictions but
none that affect nov which means that
this pocket dimension would have come
at an exorbitantly high or a cost and
just to cover a few more conjurers
gentry was another great one to bring up
the main antagonist of greed island who
was able to conjure lethal and
non-removable bombs
onto his victims and activate them
through a series of restrictions
including genthru needing to reveal
everything about his own abilities to
said victims
and even offering a dispel condition
which was to touch ganthru and say i
caught the bomber but as much crap as i
will give gen through
as a villain in the series countdown is
still a pretty scary hatsu and it goes
on to show the terrifying potency of a
conjurer who is consumed by a less than
savory task such as mass murder for
example
and combined with little flower gentra
has a pretty damn powerful set of
abilities and also from some more recent
hunter hunter there was a conjurer who
caught my eye by the name of henry
bigendofno which is one of those classic
tagashi examples of
how annoying can i make this name to
pronounce yeah
henry bikindofno that'll do but with
that said he has a really fun
conjuration ability known as biohazard
in which he can turn any device he
touches into a living creature which is
a very different exploration of
conjuration than we've encountered
elsewhere because usually conjuration
creates an object from aura but this is
a more strange application whereby henry
is manipulating the structure of an
existing object
and giving it life through aura and
speaking of manipulation he can also
then go on
to issue orders to his living creations
so manipulation is almost certainly
involved here as well but that is a
fairly simple breakdown of conjuration
it can be used for really whatever the
user wants so long as their needs
require an object or a living thing
to fulfill which in 99 of cases you can
structure abilities to do exactly that
i would also say that conjuration is
probably one of the more underrated nand
disciplines along with manipulation and
emission because they sound really
straightforward and like there's not a
lot of opportunity for really extensive
and creative use but that
could not be further from the truth but
what do you guys think please do leave
your thoughts in the comments below or
even join my discord server and if
you're keen for some more hunt hunter
content then please do feel free to
check out some of my other videos
or even subscribe to the channel for
regular hunt hunter glory delivered
straight into your youtube feed
but for now this has been the new world
review and i'll see you next time